December 31st 1999 a group of live
streamers have been partying all night
in the basement of a New York City
building what they didn't know was that
the FBI was about to raid their
underground bunker they had been told
that there was this doomsday cult and
that there was going to be like you know
some mass suicide or something today
streamers come face to face with law
enforcement all too often but when the
FBI arrived at 353 Broadway they quickly
realized that this was no prank phone
call interrogation rooms public showers
free drugs and even a gun range stocked
with automatic weapons you know they go
downstairs they find all these bunks set
up in the church thing it's looking very
Millennium cultish in this dingy
basement live streaming had reached Peak
Insanity complete lawlessness had led to
chaos but miraculously these dark
beginnings would ultimately be overcome
and morph into the professional live
streaming Community we see today just a
few decades later Amazon would buy
twitch for a billion dollars streamers
would start signing multi-million dollar
contracts and hundreds of millions of
viewers would watch live streams
regularly I had to know if there was a
link between the twitch we know today
and the basement cult that came face to
face with the FBI all those years
earlier so I called up Justin Khan one
of the founders of Klipsch so Justin did
you know about the Millennium live
streaming cult
[Music]
okay so it's the 1990s friends is on TV
people had just started getting cell
phones this is your current cell phone
and the internet was in its infancy but
one startup was way ahead of everyone
else just look at this the site had
streaming video live chat and it even
covered gaming content sounds familiar
right this startup was called sudo.com
and it basically had all the same
features as twitch sudo right now as we
sit here is the first internet
television network that's Josh Harris
the founder of sudo Josh had a vision of
what the internet could be but to get
there he needed money
hello I'm Josh Harris president of
Jupiter Communications
for sudo Josh realized that companies
needed statistics about the internet to
build their businesses
he built a research team and started
selling reports to financial analysts I
made up my first report it sold four or
500 copies at 300 bucks a pop and
amazingly his forecasts always seemed to
come true if you were on Wall Street in
the 1990s and you wanted to know about
the internet Josh was your guy Josh had
a vision at a very young age and he was
telling me there was this whole new
thing that was coming where we're going
to be able to communicate with each
other over this network with cash
pouring in from his reports Josh began
coming up with new ideas he saw that
more and more people were getting
internet access every day but more
importantly he understood their desires
and how to exploit them and so he
started building chat rooms most of them
adult themed obviously this was the 90s
way before slack and Discord online chat
was a novelty but these racy chats wound
up accounting for 20 of all billable
chat hours in the United States it
wasn't long before Josh had sold these
chat rooms and walked away a
multi-millionaire but that was nothing
next Josh took his research company
public the IPO landed him 80 million
dollars and all of a sudden he was the
hottest thing in the New York City Tech
scene you could just watch your wealth
grow
you don't believe it it's irrational to
you all that money led to Josh living an
absolutely wild lifestyle he was
constantly throwing parties in New York
City that Drew in all sorts of people I
open the door it's like a wave going on
in supermodels like wearing close to no
clothes sitting on the laps of nerds
playing Doom that's Jason callicanus a
famous angel investor who wrote checks
to the founders of uber and Robinhood
we'll come back to him later in this
story Josh's party lifestyle would
ultimately be his downfall but while
the.com boom was raging he had plenty of
ideas for new businesses
by 1994 Josh wanted to take chat rooms
to the next level TV was still King but
with sudo.com viewers could not just
watch but interact with what's on their
screen people born after the 90s can't
really understand how insane this was
back in those days
text messaging wasn't even widespread at
this point it's hard to imagine a time
when people weren't looking down at
their phones all the time but this was
the 90s the internet was extremely early
Little Wing who was a new viewer Pappy
is a new viewer we got some new people
out there oh boy where's getting around
I was genius because nobody has done it
yet and that was the future that's where
it was going to go it was going to be
interactive television the early
adopters loved live streaming Jason
calacanus was one of them and he even
hosted a show about tech
welcome to the Silicon alley reporter
net TV show let me get myself on the
screen here perfectly so you can see me
with your real video player G3 but sudo
wasn't exactly professional on the
inside walls were covered in graffiti
and I mean look at this footage these
weren't your typical office socials I
suspect there have been people on
illegal drugs that are hallucinogenic
drugs that have been on this elevator
and it's seemingly ended this ride even
though TV was still King live streaming
had an edge targeted advertising what's
the Competitive Edge I'm much more
efficient television my advertisers can
be delivered a very specific audience
and guess what my audience can be
counted because they're computers Josh
recognized that live streaming was all
about spectacle and pushing boundaries
he even invented a character this guy
lovey the clown we still see this
over-the-top style in streamers today
plenty of live streamers play a
character in order to attract attention
and Josh understood this but he was
slowly losing his grip on reality that'd
say you're out of your mind what's wrong
with you you just wanted to go like and
slap him over the head every time he
sort of brought out lovies Josh's
bizarre behavior got worse and would
ultimately lead him to leave sudo.com
but it was his next project where he
finally took it too far
partially in a van partially a party and
partially a social experiment
called it quiet we live in public and
Josh sunk Millions into this project
down here we're building a capsule hotel
to find out what the internet is going
to look like when it takes over costs
about 250 000 to build the Pod structure
with an additional hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to build the internal
cable network 150 000 to feed everyone
three hundred thousand dollars from
miscellaneous artists and events this
place was insane they had drugs booze
interrogation rooms any techniques that
we can use to to intimidate them
you know to break them in in essence do
you try to commit suicide yes show me
the speed with which the knife was
having to reflection
it was a very frightening experience in
fact it was torture
and even an indoor gun range stocked
full of ammunition yeah where's the gun
range it sounds good I want to see the
guy you want to shoot guns I do
Mystic bunker and the rules were simple
don't bring your money with you
everything is free except the video that
we capture of you that we own but the
project wasn't just about having fun
Josh ran the bunker like an
authoritarian cult the image I have in
my mind is like in a concentration camp
you know those pictures where they're
all they're all facing forward
attendees had to answer deeply personal
questions and give their social security
numbers everything was filmed everything
they even had cameras in the bathrooms
and public showers by the way there is
so much I can't show on YouTube but I
highly recommend that you check out the
documentary which I'll link below it's a
fascinating watch and a great source of
footage for this video in Josh's mind no
one would have privacy in the future so
why here Andy Warhol was actually wrong
his view is of course that people want
15 Minutes of Fame in their lifetime our
view is that people want 15 minutes of
fame every day Josh in some ways was
right we allow Facebook and Google to
track everything we do and we openly
share our lives on social media but even
20 years later the impact of the
internet has been far more moderate than
Josh predicted yes there are some people
who stream their lives for hours on end
but that's certainly not the norm
probably one of the safer places to be
in New York City
debauchery couldn't go on forever and so
on the turn of the Millennium the cops
raided the bunker
[ __ ]
people are not supposed to stay in the
hotel anymore
foreign
something crazy happens when you point a
camera at someone
desire for fame and attention is so
strong that social norms seem to fly out
the window but this erratic Behavior
wasn't contained to just Josh's crazy
experiment most of those incidents have
been repeated on Twitch at some point in
time even Dr disrespect tried to live
stream in a bathroom although he was
banned immediately for this Josh's
obsession with live streaming didn't
stop there he went on to wire up his
entire house like a we live in public
version 2.0 we rigged a camera inside
the refrigerator camera in the cat box
infrared cameras in the bedroom the 72
highly sensitive microphones Josh and
his girlfriend laid their entire lives
bare but the openness took its toll on
Josh's mental health and I've been
living with you know continuous
surveillance of cameras that combination
is not designed for mental stability in
health that's right I'm sick I'm
mentally sick right now It ultimately
led him to becoming violent and
psychotic
[Music]
Josh would
leave to an apple farm nearly broke and
no longer revered as a tech genius
story sounds familiar to me this is
Justin Khan who would go on to become
the founder of twitch Justin also rigged
up his house for 24 7 live streaming
here with Justin from Justin.tv which is
a website that broadcasts your life Live
24 7 from your point of view everything
from you know going on dates to walking
around
straight to having business meetings
everything is on camera live streaming
video with chat rooms the resemblance
between sudo and twitch is uncanny even
while researching this video I saw he
followed the director of the we live in
public documentary and so I had to know
how much inspiration did Justin take
from Josh's experiments when he streamed
his life and is Twitch inspired by the
original pseudo site
hey Justin thanks for taking the call
I'm really excited to talk to you yo
that's great to talk to you finally
after watching all these YouTube videos
I've had this I've had this thought in
my mind since I watched this documentary
we live in public when you first started
out thinking about doing Justin TV
streaming your life had you heard about
what happened with we live in public and
Josh Harris yeah so I guess I found out
about it later after we had already come
up with the idea and people told me but
the documentary hadn't come out yet so
yeah uh the documentary came out a
couple years after the Justin TV
experiment of me streaming my life to
the internet 24 7. so you know I heard
this like oh yeah this guy tried this
and he was doing it in a warehouse in
Brooklyn or something right like he was
in New York but outside of that I didn't
really know really what happened to him
I I and I'm I guess I'm I've always been
someone who hasn't done very you know
that much research in any ways so if you
had known that this guy live streamed
his whole life and had this kind of
breakup and had like a pretty rough go
of it do you think that would have
intimidated you or do you think you
would have been like you know what I can
do it better
be better I love that yeah so there you
have it the twitch team only found out
about Josh Harris after they had already
started building but it wouldn't have
stopped them anyway don't let previous
failure stop you from building the
future if you're not already subscribed
to Justin head on over there now and if
you want to know what Justin's
co-founder Kyle went on to do after
launching twitch just watch this video
next thanks for watching
foreign